esta es la primera visita del presidente
nicolás maduro a irán desde que asumirá
la presidencia el clérigo ibrahim rise y
hace un año ha dicho que han sostenido
conversaciones telefónicas pero la
primera vez que ambos mandatarios se
encuentran las relaciones de irán y
venezuela datan desde la época del
presidente chávez especialmente con el
ex presidente mahmud ahmadineyad sin
embargo el presidente maduro dice que
viene a firmar un acuerdo por 20 años de
cooperación se encuentran reunidos ambos
mandatarios en el día de hoy en ese
palacio de sádaba donde se reciben a los
altos mandatarios donde fue recibido por
raisi y donde sostienen una reunión de
alto rango con sus principales ministros
que incluyen de agricultura y de
gobierno y también del director de
petróleos de venezuela sin embargo el
área de mayor cooperación en el momento
sería el turismo en el cual venezuela
estaría interesado atraer miles y miles
de turistas iraníes que siempre están
buscando tipo de playas
y caribe y que cada vez tienen más
difícil viajar debido a esas visas y
restricciones que tienen por las
sanciones económicas y es que ha dicho
el presidente maduro que también viene a
aprender como irán ha logrado sobrevivir
y saltarse esas sanciones económicas que
han sido impuestas desde 2018